là aujourd'hui on sait qu on est à plus
de 2 mm par an parfois 3 va dépendre des
secteurs peu reprend et toutes les
informations qui nous sont donnés parle
d'une accélération de cette montée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui est devenu problématique c'est
l'emplacement du camping et du coup le
fait qu'il ait été inondées
le rend très vulnérables on maintient
son activité
où
on
on voit bien que l'outil qu'on a
reconstruit que sur lequel nous sommes
commencent à souffrir et vous avez
l'exemple même de morceaux qui se
fissure et qui ont tendance à se pousser
et donc un jour on s'est dit on pourra
pas contenir la plage un endroit où
aller actuellement
[Musique]
la première étape s'est constitué le
camping est un autre endroit dans la
vallée un peu plus loin ça veut dire que
ça libéral l'espace du camping actuelle
mais ça veut dire qu'on va résoudre de
façon conséquente je pense le même
définitif le problème des inondations
terrestre mais on aura une entrée de
mais régulière aux grandes marées
[Musique]
grâce à ça on va avoir une modification
de diversité présente dans la vallée qui
va permettre à ce rang d'espèce de venir
se reproduire ici
je trouve que ça va peut-être perturbé
les habitudes il ya beaucoup d'habitués
j'ai l'impression des gens qui ont
coutume d'aller sur la plage faire de la
pêche à pied bon là ils vont être un
petit peu plus loin ceci dit je pense
que c'est une nécessité que y'a pas
moyen de faire autrement moi je préfère
comme ça c'est donc la mer reprend ses
droits de toute façon et que qui a
peut-être des siècles en arrière c'était
pas habiter c'était la meilleure tout
simplement
[Musique]